[Applause]
foreign
all right it's me Tom shallou let's
welcome tonight's guests
she put herself through college running
moonshine co-host of the bottom line on
Fox Business Dagen McDowell
he rides a bike and he's from
Philadelphia yet somehow he's still
alive
CEO of electric bike Technologies Jason
Kraft
she's an expert on politics which for
this show makes her unique Fox News
correspondent Jillian Turner
my knight she's a popular TV personality
by day she's a professional dog walker
Fox News contributor Kat Tim
well it's been a minute since we cleaned
out the fridge so before we get to some
news stories let's do this
Greg's leftovers
yeah it's leftovers where I read some
recent jokes we didn't use and just like
when Greg does it it's my first time
reading these here we go
during a recent jail interview jillane
Maxwell claimed Jeffrey Epstein was
indeed murdered in his cell she says she
knows this because he never really liked
to hang by himself
[Music]
right
Jeff Bezos girlfriend Lauren Sanchez
revealed in an interview that in 1999
she was devastated after finding out
that she didn't land a job as one of the
co-hosts of the view but TV industry
experts say it's likely she didn't meet
the show's minimum weight requirement
but I wait a minute oh
I don't know if I would have okayed that
one President Biden is rolling out a
renter's Bill of Rights the prez says he
was deeply moved after hearing about a
drug addict who lived with his parents
in Delaware yet still paid 50 Grand a
month in rent
[Applause]
at least 20 dollar stores in Detroit
have been robbed this month police have
asked the public to keep an eye out for
a criminal who lacks ambition
come on a Denver area public library is
investigating traces of methamphetamine
found in their restrooms it's a sad
thought to think of drugs in a library
although it does explain the success of
their speed reading program
foreign
because of ramp and crime Nike has
chosen to permanently shut down its
flagship store in downtown Seattle and
in a related story Nike is also
introducing a brand new slogan just give
up
Tech Mogul named Brian Johnson who's 45
years old says he spends two million
dollars a year to have the body of an 18
year old but we found a picture and it's
not working
that's
fine AC DC joke okay
heck they can do it former president
Barack Obama refused to say this week
whether or not he's searching for
classified documents in his home though
I'm pretty sure it was Barack Obama who
once said if you like your classified
documents you can keep your classified
documents
yeah according to NASA 2022 was the
fifth hottest year in history in fact it
was so hot three New York City cab
drivers actually flirted with the idea
of turning the air conditioning on
so all right it's a local joke
disgrace cryptocurrency Mogul Sam
bankman freed has reportedly Enlisted
the services of a 75 pound dog trained
to attack on command using a secret code
word uh let me guess pudding
and finally under Biden's art dealer
Georges berges has claimed that Biden
will be among the most consequential
artists in this Century because his art
gives us hope yes it really does we hope
he quits painting real soon
all right
okay now to some news will labeling
social media defective prove effective
plaintiffs are expected to file a
lawsuit next month against meta the
parent company of Facebook and Instagram
for the alleged damages they've done to
America's mental health the case hinges
on a legal theory that algorithms are
defective products that encourage
addictive behavior and are governed by
existing product liability law however
legal experts say the law traditionally
applies to tangible stuff like a car or
a toaster and in some cases a presidency
the lawsuit argues social media Giants
knew their algorithms encouraged users
to view mentally harmful posts that
cause eating disorders anxiety and
depression coincidentally the same
symptoms you get for working for Greg
gutfelt
[Laughter]
so that's the deal Jillian do you
believe this do obviously social media
it's got its problems but can you sue
yes you can sue because a whole slew of
states are now suing various social
media platforms there's been this effort
across the government to ban various
platforms on government devices I will
also say for somebody
um
who wants to be sensitive to the issues
of the daytime you had a lot of fat
jokes now I didn't I'm trying to decide
how I feel about that yeah I mean look
it's what you you got to do whatever the
writers tell you on the show apparently
another word about this lawsuit if I
make
they are not just accusing these social
media companies of encouraging addictive
behavior remember these platforms by
Design according to their own Founders
are literally created in order to
perpetuate addiction right that's all
the algorithms are all geared towards
um you know instigating more clicks yeah
that is addictive behavior they've kind
of admitted it right don't they do that
Jason I think this uh Zuckerberg at meta
he's bragged about it when he goes to
Advertiser she says you know we've
cracked the code people are addicted to
our platforms right yeah that's true I
don't think you should ban anything
though not not any American company like
stop Banning things well it's about
parents who don't take care of their
kids like get some personal
responsibility it's not Facebook's fault
you let your kid hang out on there all
the time or something like that right
yeah what do you think about there
there's a lot of people trying to ban
Tick Tock they say oh that's China well
that's why I said it'll burn them out
because of China that's why I said
American I use WeChat a lot I do
business in China and um there I'm not
like I always know I always know they're
watching I make electric bikes no I know
I'm joking oh
you missed it thank you
it's true Kat uh do you think this could
be a successful lawsuit no I look I
think it's dumb so that would be my
legal ruling it's dumb just dumb to sue
well no because I so I'm one of those
people that doesn't think guns kill
people people kill people so I also
think that you know if social media
makes you bet feel bad about yourself
from looking at social media it's the
people that make you feel bad about
yourself I'm looking at social media
because everybody looks the best on
social media you never look like that
and I mean I can totally admit that like
when I post a picture of myself on
Instagram by the time you look at it I
don't look like that anymore
I look like Beth from Little Women like
right before the scarlet fever takes her
but except with less hair
so you just have to acknowledge that I
try to be transparent so I wear a lot of
hair extensions I have a lot of makeup
on like this is me with bronzer Believe
It or Not uh and you have to kind of
acknowledge that because it can make you
feel bad but if you're so like you know
social media makes you feel bad and it
can be you know like wait till wait till
I tell you about people it's so true
Dagan it's personal responsibility right
I mean people have to know at this point
that these things aren't good for you
and you've got to regulate you gotta
self-regulate well the people
are defect
s or they ever go on the social
say that as a person with major defects
I am the four Pinto of the McDowell
family
you smack me on the ass I explode
um like the talk and the gram and the
twit they will make your crazy worse
because you go online and Cat's a
testament to this you go online for
positive reinforcement and reassurance
from people who are equally bat winged
bananas yeah like oh everybody loves my
new Madonna look I you know my shaved
eyebrows and my big puffed up souffle
mouth and my hairline that starts
somewhere back behind my ears everybody
just thinks I'm awesome
but then again in Reverse it can maybe
take away some of the nuttiness when
maybe everybody realizes that Madonna
with her big puffed up souffle mouth
coming along our friends because she
can't leave her mouth yeah so maybe it
has a positive effect on the real world
but what if you're like eight right none
of us we're all really young on this
show today yeah but none of us are young
enough to have grown up on these apps
right like what if you start looking at
this stuff when you're like a kid
imagine how crazy when you're an adult
well we need to burn their parents
oh well no not literally you mean expose
them expose the parents well you know
it's interesting
when when uh what's the one that
Snapchat when Snapchat first came out
because the snaps disappeared everyone
said this is really nasty because people
are going to use it to sext each other
but then uh they they found out that
actually Snapchat users had a healthier
relationship because the things
disappear and on Instagram a lot of
especially young girls they they get
obsessed with the image whether it gets
likes or not because it stays there it's
permanent so the permanence was causing
more insecurity does that make sense to
you I mean I can only imagine that it
does like Dayton said if you're like
that's some made-up research you just
called that's what we're into on this
show you just made that up
you don't believe that burns like Salem
Witch Trials I meant but who thinks that
it's okay an eight-year-old is on social
media yeah no I don't think so I think
I'm doing I'm doing the Invasion of the
Body Snatchers point and Screech at any
parent who is letting their small
children on social
by the way kids don't like Facebook like
Facebook's the most uncool thing for
kids that's like LinkedIn I have three
kids they like Facebook yeah that's for
old people right yeah we don't have to
worry about the kids on Facebook other
stuff maybe but in fact I think this
thing could be this is the kind of uh
lawsuit that I think Democrats like
because they don't want us looking into
the real thing that Facebook did was
affect the last election because they
were taking down any posts that were
favorable to Republicans and boosting
anything that were favorable to
Democrats am I right about that audience
yeah
I know where to go at the end of the
segment hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else